la estación de policía donde javier
oldoni es pasó sus últimos momentos
antes de ser trasladado a una clínica
donde falleció fue el epicentro de las
protestas la indignación de la
ciudadanía está a flor de piel
mira lo que pasó con la policía mataron
a muchos chicos como pasó en los eeuu le
colocaron electricidad a su cuerpo le
presionaron el pecho hasta mataron le
dieron patadas hasta que lo mataron es
más doloroso ver cómo dos niños se
quedan sin padre que ver un calle rayado
eso es una estupidez al lado del
problema que en realidad se estaba
viviendo y que es de todos los días ayer
porque fue un muerto pero todos los días
vivimos los abusos de la gente de los
policías es sin embargo otro sector de
la ciudadanía rechaza los actos de
violencia por parte de los manifestantes
porque están en la forma de reaccionar o
sea uno puede llamar la atención es ir
oye las cosas no las hagan de esta
manera de una manera pacífica pero ya
cuando la cosa se convierte en
salvajismo cuando ya las personas actúan
de manera irracional no como seres
humanos sino irracionales porque el daño
que están haciendo ahorita es mucho más
grave porque es a nivel general cierto
ahorita a estos costos nos sacan a
nosotros del bolsillo porque tenemos que
pagar impuestos de los daños que los que
se les ocurre hacer esta diligencia si
con la alcaldía de bogotá hay por lo
menos 15 manifestaciones convocadas para
la noche de los jueves y aunque no hay
toque de queda las autoridades piden
evitar estar en las calles de la capital